[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's halloween so of
course today was the day congress took
its first official step toward
impeaching a president the House voted
232 to 196 to approve a resolution that
lays out rules for the impeachment
process it was nearly perfect party line
vote every single Republican voted
against it all the two Democrats voted
in favor of it Adam Schiff meanwhile the
congressman from Burbank was ecstatic
Schiff has spent years obsessing over
impeachment like it was a young Jodie
Foster colleagues say he has pictures of
impeachment taped to the walls of his
bedroom he's believed to have written
it's steamy unhinged letters using his
own body fluids so for chef today's vote
was thrilling in ways that only a
court-appointed psychiatrist could fully
appreciate watch him here though pretend
that it was not in fact the happiest day
of his entire adult life this is a
solemn day in the history of our country
when the president's misconduct has
compelled us to continue to move forward
with an impeachment inquiry we take no
joy in having to move down this road and
proceed with the impeachment inquiry but
neither do we shrink from it we take no
joy in this of all the many lies told at
public expense in Washington DC and
there are many that may be the most
hilariously brazen of all in at least a
generation for those of you keeping
track at home in fact for Democrats
impeachment is like winning the lotto on
Christmas but honestly seriously believe
us now we're not enjoying it not even a
little bit sackcloth and ashes were
praying for you and for the president
okay that's not real what is real is
that the public is not loving it quite
as much as Adam Schiff is new polling
appears to show support for impeachment
and some decline it's possible at voters
are simply confused by what's happening
what exactly are the charges here how do
we go from disliking Trump to trying to
remove him by force seemingly overnight
and who exactly is this whistleblower
who apparently started at all we still
don't know the answers to those the most
basic questions last night the site real
clear investigations published an
article
but the man it says is the whistleblower
as if tonight shifts office has not
denied this denied the substance of that
piece publicly available information and
corroborates some of the details in it
it's a remarkable story in any case the
man is a registered Democrat who worked
on the National Security Council as a
holdover from the Obama administration
over the years he worked for both Joe
Biden and disgraced CIA director John
Brennan a news article from 2017
identifies this same man as pro-ukraine
and anti Russia that says that he was
the subject of bitter complaints from
some Republicans who knew him in other
words more than two years ago
conservatives were publicly charging
that this man was working from inside
the building to undermine the Trump
administration according to the
RealClearPolitics piece last night they
were right the man worked with
professional left-wing activists the
piece says to attack Donald Trump he
also held meetings with Adam Schiff
staff members several of whom were his
former colleagues from the Obama White
House and tonight we can tell you it
seems likely that this man the man in
question was also a source for robert
Muller's investigation his Russia
investigation what appears to be the
man's name can be found in a footnote in
the final report well keep in mind that
just a week ago the New York Times
praised the whistleblower whoever he is
as quote a patriotic public servant his
aim the paper told us reassured us was
quote not to bring down mr. Trump out of
personal or political animus but to
rescue the Republic from his excessive
end quote so if real clears piece last
night is accurate if the reporting is
right that framing is an utter lie
virtually everything we've been told
about the whistleblower would be
misleading and intentionally so it would
be propaganda like so much we hear is it
well only Adam Schiff can clear it up he
should do that immediately for the sake
of restoring confidence in the US
government he won't do that because it
doesn't serve his political interest but
in some ways it doesn't matter we've
learned a lot from the piece anyway
whether he was the so-called
whistleblower or not the man that real
clear wrote about was a naked ly
partisan political actor in what should
be a non political position his job is
to protect the United States he has
spent his days trying to get his team
elected now that's wrong unfortunately
it's nothing
just yesterday former deputy CIA had
john mclaughlin encouraged permanent
bureaucrats here in Washington to
continue to subvert elected officials
the ones they work for thank God for the
deep state I think you know everyone
here has seen this progression of
diplomats and intelligence officers and
White House people trooping up to
Capitol Hill right now and saying these
are people who are doing their duty who
were responding to a higher call is
there anything that could shake the
public's faith in its government more
than former CIA of all agencies CIA
officials saying things like that
telling us that subverting the will of
voters is a higher call higher
apparently the democracy itself